well hello to you all and thank you for
uh your interest and lab roots and in
this particular conference
it is a privilege for me to participate
and i also wanted to thank lab roots for
organizing these events
and for scheduling these educational
webinars
so as was said my job today is to tell
you
about our experiences with testing
gesture chips
as you can see on the screen on my
toxicologist by training and
i also have an md and i came to
interacting with tissue chips as a
biomedical researcher and a mechanistic
toxicologist
and before i begin i wanted to
disclaimer a couple of years ago i was
interviewed by nature medicine for a
feature
article that they were putting together
on chip power
and a couple of quotes that
they used in that particular article
reflected how i felt about tissue chips
and microphysiological systems two years
ago
and in part my presentation today will
be a transition of me personally as a
scientist and as a toxicologist
and uh what type of confidence i was
able to build into myself and into
the stakeholders that we collaborate
with so i said that
i don't want to assume that more
complicated system is better
and as you can imagine tissue chips are
much
more complicated than traditional in
vitro systems
and i also said that i was at that time
a healthy skeptic about tissue chips and
how much promise they can actually hold
and i did feel that a number of
developers have over promised
with respect to what they can deliver
and
this was something that we've probably
all seen before with promising
technology not living up to its
expectations and perhaps
fading much sooner than it can really
deliver because the expectations were
much greater
so what we have tried to do in the last
couple of years
is to help both the bioengineers
and the end users to have greater
confidence in tissue chips as a
technology that can be used
for safety and toxicity testing and also
in other parts of drug development
so before i begin giving you
the data i wanted to thank national
center for advancing translational
sciences for funding us
uh with a two-year grant uh in 2016
and this year uh like last year they
actually
funded us again for two more years but
all of the
data that we have been able to collect
as a tissue chip testing center at texas
a m university
was really a product of four variable
post docs and technicians
and then we have a couple of people that
are helping out analytical chemistry and
i'll share some of that data with you as
well
and most importantly we have a number of
faculty who we are able to reach out for
consultation
there's really myself and dr clifford
steffen at one of our
partner organizations that have overseen
the laboratory experiments
but most important i'm very grateful to
our collaborators from nine universities
that have shared their devices with us
that have hosted our staff and their
laboratories to learn how to use their
technology
and who have stayed interacting with us
with respect to
protocols and data analysis and
interpretation
of their results so i'm really grateful
not only to principal investigators but
also to their students technicians and
postdocs
who have really gone out of their way
working with us
so i wanted to start at the very
beginning and this slide is the court
is the courtesy of dr danila togley from
ncats
and mcats is one of the funding
agencies that is part of national
institutes of health in the united
states
that has been funding a lot of
biomedical
engineering research into developing
tissue chips
so as you can see at the bottom of your
screen ncats has
provided a number of grants and i will
tell you more about them on the next
couple of slides
that are aimed to develop
microphysiological systems that
replicate organ function and structure
that can be used to test
compounds that can be actually taken
outside of the laboratory
and these particular devices are meant
to be
beyond just the publication and
something of an academic interest
they're really meant to be used by the
stakeholders and that's what you see on
the very top
the industry and regulatory agencies
really are the ones that are
prospective users of this technology and
most importantly
this particular technology if people
have confidence in it and if it really
works
can be something that contract research
organizations can provide as a service
to multiple clients to build up the data
and to
increase further confidence in using
these types of data for
decision making in regulatory
environments however as frequently
happens
there is a large gap between the people
who develop technology and people who
can be potential users of this
particular technology
and that gap in biomedical sciences is
very challenging to bridge
and mcats designed the program
to bring tissue chip testing centers who
would be
trying to be the bridge between the
technology developers and the technology
users
because there's a lot of writing not
only in terms of finances but also
advances of drug development and
chemical safety evaluation on this
so ncats issued a program announcement
in 2016
and they called for proposals that would
last for about two years
uh that would test two to three new
devices about every six months
and would have a throughput of couple of
compounds and test it for a couple of
different phenotypes
and replicate it a couple of times so
really two and a half years ago nobody
knew what
is the opportunity and whether this
distribution testing is even possible
so ncats has called this program
announcement
next-gen tissue chip testing centers
validating microphysiological system
and validation means different thing in
different contexts
what you can see on the left at fda
analytical and clinical validation is
really something that is
quite established i'm using
excuse me an example of uh us within
drug administration but
you know they're very similar principles
in europe and in other countries
and validation really is broken into
both analytical and clinical validation
and in both of these contexts one really
needs to understand how the device or
how the test will be used
and once you understand the context of
use for that particular device
you can understand where the bar is for
how good that technology should be
once you understand the use and what the
level of evidence one needs you can
actually embark on the process of
qualification and qualification of
biomarkers qualification of survey
instruments and other things
in um you know in drug world is
not an easy process that takes years and
it takes many stakeholders
now on the chemical side there's you
know a validation of alternative methods
that
many of you may be familiar with and
that's a process that is very rigorously
uh regulated and specified by a number
of
legal documents and frameworks in europe
for example
the cosmetics directive and the reach
regulation describe
what validation alternative methods
really
is then united states japan korea brazil
and other countries their very parallel
efforts
and internationally organization of
economic cooperation and development
oacd
is actually a guideline that is a
guidance document on validation and
international acceptance of new
or updated test methods for hazard
assessment and the guidelines states
that
um there are three components of three
major elements in validation there's a
testing of reliability there's a testing
of relevance
and then there has to be a purpose in
which this particular test will be used
and so when this comes to tissue chips
and
the vision that mcats had two and a half
years ago for what tissue chip testing
centers should do
it was not entirely clear which ones of
these
qualifications or validations or is it
reliability or is it relevance
and it was left to the grantees of
people who wanted to
solicit for these particular grants to
define what that meant
so first thing that we had to start with
was to define what
tissue chips are out there and mcat
specified that
the tissue chip testing centers were
only to work with
developers who have been funded by mcats
and in 2012 there was a first round of
grants awarded and all of this
information is available on ncat's
website if you just google ncats and
tissue chip
you'll be led to a website that has
plenty of information on the developers
on what they've done what they've
published and
a lot of information is provided for you
but as you can see there is a
diversity of institutions there is a
diversity of the
projects of tissues or models that have
been proposed
and we reached out to all of these and
then we ended up with about two-thirds
of the developers who are interested in
working with us
and as i will say at the end of this
presentation
you know one of the challenges is to
actually convince people who develop
technology
uh to let third party test that
technology before it actually hits
real world and that's just the reality
and i'm not
really taking sides in this myself now
when we propose
to do tissue chip testing center and as
you can see we have a tax valve
as our title and we're at the texas a m
university
in college station texas we really uh
reasoned that this is um it takes a
village to do this type of work and you
need to have experts from different
disciplines
as you can see this puzzle board at the
bottom left you need to have expertise
in toxicology analytical chemistry
and uh by engineering and microfluidics
you need to have folks who understand
how to use these data on
pharmacokinetic modeling uh there are a
lot of measurements that are being taken
that are very diverse from protein
measurements to gene expression
to images and then you have to do this
at
a glp-like environment so you have to
make sure that your work
is actually quality controlled as well
but there are other
parameters and uh core principles that
were important to us
first we really wanted to make sure that
our team of scientists is independent
of the ncats funded tissue chip
developers
so as you can see on the next click
we have a diversity of faculty and even
though some of them are by engineers
they're not funded currently by mcat so
we really had no conflict of interest
as far as we are concerned second
important thing that i wanted to
highlight is that
you really need to compare the data from
the 3d microphysiological system
to the standard in vitro culture model
it is also important to compare to the
enviro situation whenever possible
but because in principle these
microphysiological systems
are using cells then recreating some
form of a much simpler system that
probably has a higher throughput and can
be attainable
by more laboratories was something that
was very important to us and
unfortunately in the
uh bioengineering world the gestureship
development world
very few labs actually provide
comparison to the 2d systems
so we had a complicated org chart and
i'm not going to take you through it
for a very long time just to point out
that not only it takes the village of a
lot of different
people with a lot of different expertise
to have this type of a throughput to
test eight to twelve platforms in two
years
you really need to have capacity to do
this and so we were fortunate to have
two different sites at texas a m
university one in houston one in college
station it was about an hour and a half
drive between
these two facilities we had two labs in
houston and
four labs and college station that kind
of came together
and interacted on a weekly basis and
changed
exchanged compounds that changed data
changed protocol and information
but we also were interacting very
closely with our tissue chip developers
as i already mentioned
but also that's not the end of it uh
we had monthly teleconferences with our
funder and cats but also with
representatives of
various pharmaceutical companies that
have since organized into
the iq uh consortium affiliate on
microphysiological systems
and last but not least all of the data
that we're generating we're
depositing into the university of
pittsburgh systems database
this was one of the grants awarded under
this mechanism
and i again welcome you to go and
explore
microphysiological systems database
again you can just google
for that and you can easily find it
now the as i already mentioned this
type of an effort that i will describe
to you in some detail
uh took only about two years and for
those of you in academia
you certainly would appreciate that two
years is a very short
a period of time because by the time you
actually get funding in
and actually start projects hire staff
and actually
you know begin doing things you already
lost valuable time
so we had to devise a standardized
workflow that we could follow
not only for every chip but also to
organize our work and i already
mentioned that we tried to test devices
in about a six month period
because we reasoned that in the real
world whether it's a pharmaceutical or a
chemical
company or contract research
organization you know people who are not
developing the particular model will not
have
long enough staying power if it really
doesn't work in couple of months
then it's not worth investing more time
and you need to move on to something so
we try to use very similar
thinking process but you also see that
there are different tiers there are
different steps the first step
is really to establish a collaboration
and there is a tremendous amount of
legal
uh agreements that have to be negotiated
between the universities to change the
change the technology and data do other
things but to share protocols you have
to actually go in
and send staff to train in the developer
labs
and once you've through that uh then you
actually
get the devices and you try to put it
all together in your own lab and then
without sales try to see if you can
establish flow or if you can do other
things and at that step we usually
started putting chemicals on these
devices and examining
whether or not we have a lot of binding
of chemicals to these devices because
they're made of
various types of materials and many of
these materials can bind
you know compounds especially based on
their physical chemical properties
then once we are through with that we
can actually try to replicate what the
developers have
published or just about to publish and
we would develop in that process very
detailed protocols as they're standard
operating procedures
and then if we're through with that
through our conversations with our
colleagues in pharmaceutical companies
and other toxicologists we will try to
define some form of a context of use for
each of these models
and we'll try to conduct additional
studies that can gain
um additional attention from the
potential end users that can actually
answer some of the questions very
practical questions that they have
that may or may not have been addressed
in the original publication that just
described the technology itself
so um i was very pleased that over these
two years we were able to complete 11
different tissue chip platforms you can
see on the left are the diversity of
tissues and models
there's only one that was you know
similar and i will tell you more about
this we had two models of the liver
all of these is already mentioned were
funded by mcats
there are a lot of other technology uh
platforms out there there are other
universities there are other companies
that develop that we had to focus on
what was funded by mcats
we had collaborated with nine different
universities and we have
to complete a variety of uh legal
agreements with them
and we've tested seven of these in
college station and four of these in
houston and as you can see
by the end of 2018 we've been able to
take
uh 10 of the 11 all the way through tier
2 and then one of the platforms we
stopped in tier 1
because of the throughput and other
challenges that we had
if you look at the timeline more of a
gantt chart like view you see that
we started in two sites the maroon is
college station the blue is
our site in houston and we got
confidence in
working with the developers getting uh
into this workflow
and then our next period was uh more
confidence with couple of platforms in
each site
and then towards the end we really kind
of were confident in our ability to
uh run multiple platforms in parallel so
we're able to work with
three to five different platforms at the
same time
so let me give you a couple of examples
of what the data looks like
and i broken these slides into types of
profusion or lack thereof
in these particular models because for
me as a toxicologist it was very
interesting
to learn that in the field of biomedical
engineering
tissue chip or microphysiological is not
really
you know very well-defined terms and
really each laboratory defines
uh what is microphysiological what is
there is not a tissue
themselves and as long as they can
convince peer reviewers and published
papers and
if they can convince funders to get more
grants
that's how they perceive what is
microphysiological but obviously
each platform is trying to replicate
either a tissue
either organ or some part they're off
and then it actually was trying to
replicate some sort of
physiology or or anatomy on the
microscale
so a good a couple of examples were
platforms that actually have no flow
their static
cultures but they are very complicated
cultures one is
uh bone with and without tumor model
from colombia university
and what this is is essentially a plate
which has chambers and these chambers
contained in them
pieces of decelerized bovine trabecular
bone
that have been seeded with human
osteoblasts and new sarcoma cells
so it's a human tissue but there is no
flow in that tissue
and what we have done uh after repeating
the experiments that the
colleagues at columbia university did we
actually tried to do
or simulate treatment of metastasis into
the bone
and we tried to look at which drugs are
used in the clinic
and which regimens are being used so
we would first culture these platforms
after receiving them from colombia for
seven days
and then depending on the particular
treatment whether it's a cisplatin
methotrexate and christian dexamethasone
or a combination of drugs we try to
treat for
uh several consecutive days and then
have an off period and then treat again
and then evaluate uh growth of viewing
sarcoma cells
two weeks after the termination of
treatment and so we've done all of this
in comparison as i mentioned with
two-dimensional culture we're just
culture viewing sarcoma cells
and what you see here is viability uh
two weeks after termination of treatment
and we normalize everything to the uh
growth rate of the urine sarcoma cells
without any treatment that's the
controls across the top of this bar
graph
and then you can see there's a
concentration response we've tested
uh human c-max and then kind of you know
half an order of magnitude or another
magnitude above
below and you can see you can kill you
in sarcoma cells with cisplatin you can
there's a clear concentration response
with metrotraxate in both models
and christine is very effective now the
interesting difference was with
dexamethasone dexamethasone really is
not supposed to have any effect on
doing sarcoma cells but it was toxic to
the
osteoblasts and so eu and sarcoma cells
were dying as they were
losing the support of the osteoblasts
and then the combination treatment was
more effective in 3d
so there are important differences
between 2d and 3d
but there is you know the biggest
difference to me is how much variability
is there in the 3d platform because it's
very difficult to control the number of
viewing sarcoma cells that are being
seeded into this model so you have to
have an effect that is
really uh i pronounce the fact that it's
very difficult to achieve statistical
significance
and have a very good titration of
concentration responses compared to the
2g system
and you also may have some of these
unexpected effects like we've seen with
the dexamethasone
another platform that's really a static
culture but still has a
microphysiological
nature to it was a
intestinal anteroid model that was
developed jointly by
scientists at johns hopkins university
in baylor college of medicine
and this is a co-culture of different
cells
from the gut and some of them are ips
derived and some of them are primary
cells or cell
cell lines and these are propagated as
anteroids but then once you start
testing them this is really the
transwell system
where you have a monolayer of disco
culture and then you can
add drugs you know into the transwell
and then measure permeability or you can
measure permeability in the reverse
order as well
and um you know i'm not going to show
you a lot of data
but just as an example the published
data is on the left from johns hopkins
and baylor college of medicine
that we're looking at trans epithelial
electrical resistance
the measure of the barrier function of
this particular
model and as you can see the tier is
going up with days of differentiation
that's what you need to see
and on the right is very similar data
obtained by our colleagues in houston
the trans-epithelial electrical
resistance goes up as it should be
uh going and then the permeability to uh
fits the label deck strand
is is actually decreasing so again the
barrier does take a couple of day two
days to establish but it is a pretty
nice barrier that you can test
and again i will not uh you know belabor
the point of the amounts of data that
we've
collected with this model system we've
tested two dozen different
drugs and this is a graph of how we
selected these
drugs there's actually a lot of data on
kco2
model versus human absorption in the gut
and we've tried to test compounds that
actually have
you know very good concordance with the
compounds that actually don't have a
very good concordance between kco2
and human absorption and all of this
data will be
uh submitted for publication last couple
of months as we're still working through
analytical chemistry on these data
now the other uh types of platforms that
we've seen were based on profusion but
it's a profusion that is driven by
gravity so there are no
uh pumps that are involved in this
particular
experiment and all you have is as
the example on the left of the heart on
the chip or cardiac model
from university california berkeley you
can see um
the model is pretty small two of these
uh chips can fit on one
uh histological slide uh in the middle
on the top you see the there's about 50
000
cardiomyocytes that are tightly packed
into a chamber and then the perfusion is
actually happening
along the sides so there's a passive
diffusion of media and drug
into the system and then you can see on
the
top right that there are pipette tips
that are filled with media
and then the media just flows from one
side to the next and then it
equilibrates and then you can replace
the media
next day or in a couple of days and we
unfortunately cannot show you the movies
these are the two slides on the
on the bottom in this box but you can
see that
you know these are different experiments
and the reproducibility of how many
cells we can actually get into this
chamber is actually pretty
good and the types of data that we're
collecting is
actually beating so there's a video
microscopy of these cells uh
beating after a couple of days of
culture in this chamber
and it's very well known that you can
get cardiomyocytes to beat in culture in
the traditional
2g system and what you see in blue
on the middle left is these
cardiomyocytes beat in
both directions kind of there's not a
directionality of beating
but our colleagues from berkeley have
published on this model they've shown
that
if you pack them into this particular
chamber
you force them to beat only in one
direction so that you can actually
measure contractility i'll be we didn't
do this in our experiments
and at the bottom you can see that we
can establish the same directionality of
beating if you see collar
that means that the cells are pulling in
one direction and they're not pulling
in the orthogonal direction and then you
can test
different drugs and concentration
response you can do
kind of escalation of the dose in the
same device or you can
do other time series or other types of
experiments and you can derive
effective concentrations and you can
compare those to the c-max or
or other types of experiments and again
you can see that
both us and the developers have
published uh
the developers have published a couple
of papers where they've compared
their results to those of human cmax a
couple of
known drugs and these were very similar
which gives confidence in this
technology
that we have not published our data yet
but we get very similar data which again
uh you know is is a good result and
something that we're very glad
to see another model that is based on
uh gravity-driven profusion albeit not
with the
pipette tips but more of the reservoirs
and that particular platform is the
vascularized tumor model from your
california irvine
labs and this particular model
if you see on the right their first
generation was
you know a glass slide with
actual chambers that were filled with
media they have since miniaturized this
into more of a 96
uh well uh plate like um
organization they're actually 12 devices
because each has a number of chambers
that are actually constituting one
device but you know this is higher
throughput because you can actually work
with
12 devices at the same time so this is
data from a publication from the
developers
you can see that uh endothelial cells
that are seeded
together with cancer cells form
networks and in red are endothelial
cells and they're very nice networks
and then in green or fluorescent cancer
cells and in this particular experiment
they had four different
cancer cell lines that were sealed into
their devices
and then you can add different drugs to
this
you know passive perfusion system and
you can compare
cytotoxicity of those anti-cancer drugs
both in a 2g system and in the 3d system
so it's you know not a technology that's
you know very easy to establish however
in our lab we
were able to successfully not only
establish these endothelial cell
networks
we can see on top is the phase contrast
image and then on the middle in red
is endothelial cell network and then at
the bottom
in green is the same device that has
been profused
from one side with fits the dextran so
not only these are cords of endothelial
cells these are actually perfusable
channels and as you can see if it's a
dextran entered on one side
actually fills in the network of the
vessels
in this particular device and again
there's a lot of data that we have
generated
that i don't have time to go into right
now
now the last couple of devices that i
wanted to show you
are actually active perfusion or pump
driven
uh systems and again there are you know
additional complications with this so
the first example i wanted to give you
is the proximal tubule
device that was developed at the
university of washington
and uh this device is based on a
commercial chip from company called
nordis that can be used couple of
different ways and i'll show you
on the next couple of slides an
alternative way this chip was used
but in essence this is a part of a
nephron
this is not kidney on the chip this is
you know doesn't have a
glomerulus but you there are a lot of
questions about drugs and chemicals
and there are effects in the proximal
tubules so it does
you know represent a very useful
microphysiological model
and then once you actually you know put
this all together it's a channel
that is lined up with renal proximal uh
kugel
epithelial cells and this is the channel
that is perfused with media
this is the uh system that can be either
enclosed in these particular
enclosures that you can acquire from
loris
and in the middle here you can see how
this is all
looking in the standard tissue culture
incubator you can fit
about 24 of these chips and
you know one challenge with these models
is they are not
you know a 24-hour or one-week
experiments
it takes about a week to actually get
the channel
uh established and refusable and then
after that you can do this experiment
for a couple of weeks and cells survive
quite nicely
and so we both use the uh the devices
from nordis
and just the regular syringe pumps
that are much more economical way of
doing these experiments
the results are essentially the same so
it's not how fancy your devices
are your setup is is how technically
skilled you are and also how
well you can differentiate between
different cell sources
so the results of this particular
technologies have been
technology had been published couple
months ago and this is an open access
publication i invite you to
go and find this and read it in greater
detail
but one of the things that we were
really interested in is whether there is
a difference in
where you get the rp tax so our
collaborators from university of
washington have shared with us
a couple of aisles of
more or less primary rp text that they
have isolated
from donor tissue
at the university of washington and then
we procured cells from wanza which is a
commercial supplier and there are other
companies as well and there was
no particular reason we have used cells
from lungs or some
not a biochain for that particular
source in any way
and here this is the data on gene
expression as you can see these
particular cells
from both sources express
kidney-specific
biomarkers both injury biomarkers are
kidney metabolism and transport
biomarkers
one important thing i wanted to point
out is that the basal expression
are dramatic for important things like
kim-1
you can see habcr1 which is the team one
is expressed at the much
higher level in wanza cells and
but then lipocalyn cm2 is actually
expressed at low levels but still you
can see that
in more primary architects versus ones
that you can get from lonza
but then what we did with these data we
actually compared gene expression
profiles to
human kidney cortex data from another
nih
project called tissue gene expression
consortium gtex
and as you can see it can make cortexes
on the top and red
and our two different architects in
culture
either 2d or 3d or towards the bottom
so they're not really identical in their
gene expression profile to kidney cortex
but what you can see is it's really
doesn't matter how you culture these
cells it's the cell source that is
actually driving the
differences in gene expression and then
the figure on the bottom right
shows that with different treatments
that we have subjected these cells to
advantage in expression profiling again
you have grouping or clustering
of cells or data by their source rather
than by the actual treatment and that's
a very important point to recognize
now the actual experiments that we
described in this study
uh were again comparing and contrasting
m31 and bonza cells
and you can culture these cells for up
to 28 days
both in 2d and in 3d you can see the
channel
3d in fluidic you see the cells are
elongated with the flow
and they're more haphazard and scattered
in the 2d culture
and then you know kim-1 levels again are
much much higher in lonza cells than
in the m31 rp text and again they kind
of you know
steady up uh as you go on with culture
and this is you know a very healthy
culture if you're not treating it with
anything
and we really aim to replicate what the
developers have published so on the
right you can see key data
from webinar all 2016 publication kidney
international
and what our collaborators did they not
only described the model they also
put this model to the test with respect
to its physiology so in the middle on
the right you see that they have looked
at
uh switch and vitamin d metabolism uh
with you know
addition of calcitriol and then also
adjustability of cytokine for 15
24 a1 when you actually switch the
vitamin d metabolism and at the bottom
they found that as they lower ph of
their perfusion media they actually see
an increase in ammonia generation
so we tried to replicate these key
elements of their publication plus we
also tested
polymax and v effects and that's those
are panels across the top and the middle
ones
and you can see that polymex and b was
toxic to rptex
in 2d in both lonzon m31 cells but him
31 cells were very resilient
to power mix and be in 3d system when
lonza cells really died off
in the 3g chip and
important point of biomarkers of injury
kim won you can see it go up very early
if you can collect enough refusate
in these models but as you can see with
lots of cells at 48 hours you see kim 1
is actually going down
and it's not because there's less
toxicity there's actually fewer to no
cells to generate quinoa and to shed
that
into the media but more important or
interesting findings were with vitamin d
metabolism we found that both him one
team 31 cells and monza cells induced
cytochrome before 50 24 a1
in 3d culture not in 2d culture when we
added calcitriol
but we did not see the change in
metabolite formation
with lonza cells when but with hemp31
cells we saw a very similar effect
as in the published publication but
with ammonia genesis we actually found
an opposite result so as we lowered the
ph of the media
we saw decreased ammonia generation so
we overall concluded in that paper that
the key elements
as far as physiology vitamin d
metabolism ingestibility of the
metabolic enzymes is
reproducible however some of the you
know experiments probably
do depend very uh greatly on a
particular donor of cells or a
particular soil
source of cells that you get but if you
can re
as you probably remember we also had
this you know
last tier which is trying to define the
context of use and trying to do
more than the developers have done
themselves as they were developing the
technology
and what we've done uh we've tested a
variety of
nephrotoxic drugs platinugentamycin and
cadmium
and we have shown that there was a time
dependent and concentration dependent
toxicity
that we can replicate in this model and
then
more importantly we have collected a
number of
data points trying to understand whether
this particular model can be used for
pharmacokinetic modeling
and again that particular data is still
under review uh
being submitted but the complication of
the pvpk model
pk modeling of this particular chip that
is a single compartment there is really
not a blood
compartment there is not a filtration in
this particular system
so we're only measuring reabsorption of
swords kind of deposit or disappearance
of a chemical from a perfusate
but we were able to replicate with
cisplatingentomizer and cadmium actually
very closely
the um the clearance and reabsorption
when we combined both the data that we
collect and a pbpk model
that was developed for this particular
instance as you can see cis platinum
clearance to filtration rate is greater
than one
in vivo and we have replicated that for
gentamicin
it's about even clearance and glomerular
filtration and then cadmium as
being you know clearance is much lower
than filtration so it's being actively
reabsorbed
we can establish that and the
conclusions that we drew from that
particular study is that particular
reabsorption
uh can be um estimated with this
particular model
you really need the pbk model to
draw some conclusions about the overall
clearance but
much greater confidence can be gained by
potential end users if you actually have
a tubular secretion component as well
and that's exactly the direction that
our collaborators university of
washington have taken
they've developed the next generation of
this model where they're you know two
parallel tubes
and this is the model that we will be
testing actually in
february march and april of uh 2019.
now another example of a refusable
system is uh
two models of the liver uh these
this one on the top was developed at the
university of pittsburgh by uh
les taylor and larry vernetti and it's a
nordist chip that uses a different
part of the chip there is a chamber that
is filled with
cells not only out of size but also
other non-parenchymal cells
and you can see an image of how this
actually looks
in the incubator the pump is in the
incubator because the perfusion distance
is pretty short
and we've tested both primary human
capacities from thermal and also ips
derived from fujifilm hepatocytes
and we've it takes about two days to
establish this
platform and then we tested it for up to
14 days you can sample media day or you
can also do imaging
daily on this platform the second one
was from university of california
berkeley from kevin keely
this is a device that is made in dr
healy's laboratory it's actually
a chain two uh channel system it's
one channel divided by uh a
membrane so you seed cells and in this
particular case only hepatocytes
without breakable cells into one chamber
and then you perfuse through a different
chamber and again it's a
actively perfused system it takes about
one day to test and we again tested
the cells that developers tested from
the different suppliers the primary
hepatitis
from wanza and then the same supply or
ips derived
parasites and imaging is a big challenge
with this particular model because the
membrane is on a fluorescent
and that really gives you a problem with
seeing into the device
so just to show you a couple of data
points
folks usually test the functionality of
parasites and culture
by measuring albumin and urea nitrogen
secretion
we can see the dotted lines with thermo
primary hepatocytes
these levels are low in 2d culture and
then in 3d culture
both ourselves and your pittsburgh
collaborators who have the same batch of
cells
we have very similar results and albumin
levels and
urea nitrogen levels are very high and
maintained over
up to two weeks and then with berkeley
device
we had a different source of hepatocytes
that really
had the opposite result there was no
albumin secretion and blood urine
nitrogen
levels really went way down so here one
cannot conclude whether it's a device or
the hepatocytes from that particular
donor that particular source that were
the reason why this was not a very good
result
but when you have the same type of cells
and in this particular case fujifilm
solar dynamics international ips drives
battery size with the same
npc fraction we actually have found that
we have a very similar result to the one
we showed with thermal hepatocytes
and in this case we could compare it
across two different platforms
again the results are very very similar
so it's not the device it's actually the
source of cells
that is very important something that we
have found with the kidney device as
well
but the functionality is not ending with
just albumin and urea nitrogen so
metabolism is very important and we've
done a lot of experiments one example
i'm going to show you
with adding to phenidine to the
perfusion media and then measuring both
affinity and information of exophanidine
that requires metabolism by cytochrome
p453a4
and as you can see in 2d on the left
uh in the first day of uh culture we do
have flex offended information but that
metabolism really
goes away as you keep culturing these
cells but in a 3d system tax-offended
information
is uh consistent as we add uh as we
change media and add more terf energy
and we actually
form flexophanidine very consistently
and then with uh icel hepatocytes very
similar results
uh in 2d there's metabolism
uh over first couple of days but then
there's a very consistent metabolism
over time
in the 3d culture and then with berkeley
along the hepatocytes not surprisingly
or not doing much
with respect to metabolism past day one
but then
when you have eye cell hepatocytes and
the berkeley device in 3d on the bottom
right
you see again a formation of
exophenidine that is very consistent
i'll be perhaps at the slightly slower
levels
than in the university of pittsburgh
device so our conclusions from this
particular experiment the 2d cultures as
everyone knows are really not suitable
for metabolism studies
but then these 3d microphysiological
devices from both
uh laboratories really maintain
metabolic function as much as
they maintain the basic functionality of
hepatocytes
and it's you know again what we've seen
before the source of cells is very
important
and cdi cells are something that is
reproducible from the same donor
and as we all know asides from their
primary
will be exhausted eventually and having
a different batch or a different donor
may reproduce experiment to experiment
variability
so let me conclude with a couple of
slides here so what have we learned
doing testing of microphysiological
systems over two years
first thing that surprised me that we
were actually able to do this
it sounds daunting to be able to
transfer technology that is very
complicated from different labs
but once you have dedicated staff and
once you understand
what the workflows are and what you have
help from the developers
it is actually possible and again i'd
like to appreciate both staff that we
had here
and also our collaborators who have gone
out of their way to help us
establish this technology transfer it's
also very important that all of our data
are
in the university of pittsburgh
microphysiological database and over two
years we have run
about 1500 different chips and about
5000
you know 2d experiments we have
collected tens of thousands
of data points and hundreds of images
and all of this information will be
available one year after we have
concluded
depositing the data into the university
of pittsburgh microphysiological
systems database i invite all of you to
access that site
and and start visiting that regularly
because the data will be released
our kidney data for example is uh is now
in public domain
now detailed descriptions of all the
phenotypic endpoints and
equipment that's necessary and very
detailed protocols this is also
something that we'll be adding to the
university of episode microphysiological
systems database
this is very important for the potential
use of this technology by end users
because it's not enough to just have a
publication and then materials methods
section
or even a protocol from a developer lab
from people who actually do this every
day so the
detailed protocols that we develop would
be potentially very very useful
there are very typical challenges every
platform is different and
we do not stop to be surprised how
different these technologies are
and you have to have a very open mind
working with any of them
but uh what we found is not all
developers are open to sharing their
technology
and that's okay i mean not everyone is
willing to
give their devices to someone else to
try and test
some of the devices and the quality you
know have to make them that there's a
lot of material
science and there's a lot of uh you know
lithography and printing
that it goes into that and the rigorous
quality controlling of devices
themselves is very very
important likewise uh quality of cells
that are used in microphysiological
systems and devices is equally important
sometimes these cells are not available
especially if uh develo
if the platforms were developed with
primary cells
and then there are you know different
devices have different levels of
technical complexity and you have to be
prepared
to deal with that but there are also a
lot of opportunities
we are continuing this work for the next
two years we have six our existing
partners
and five new partners who have agreed to
continue working with us and we have 19
microphysiological systems that we aim
to test in the next two years from 2018
to 2020
we do see that developers are generally
interested in the feedback that we
provide
and then a number of stakeholders both
folks and the pharma and the chemical
industry are generally interested in our
experiences
and we are doing a lot of visits to talk
to them about what we have found and how
this technology can really be imported
but
i really am uh or feeling that i'm a
representative or potential customer so
i do have
a number of thoughts as well to share
with you i do believe that this
technology is extremely useful and very
promising
and that by engineering research and
development needs further support
however the applications of these
fischer chips will be highly fit for
purpose
and i do not believe that in the short
term
the next three to five years these
disasters will really replace
animals or even in vitro studies i you
know hope that some of these devices
will be ready but in reality we're
in the short term we're not replacing
animal testing and for all of you
listening
i think you have to you know really um
you know believe in this technology to
start replacing data that you're used to
from
standard in vitro studies or from animal
studies
but the developers also need to
appreciate the
need for portability and ease of use and
reasonable cost of these devices these
are not easy to work with these are not
less expensive than traditional in vitro
studies or even animal studies
and so where that balances between the
throughput and the cost of this
complicated technology
you know i'm not sure we have a very
good comfort more understanding of that
yet
and when people think that really it's
the bridge between the developers and
then the regulatory agencies
i think that first bridge is between the
developers and then the users who will
develop data
who will then go to the regulatory
agencies but the end users companies
that a lot of you are listening really
need to be ready to be thinking about
these technologies and they need to
have the workforce that is ready to
start working with this you know
toxicologist toxicologists or biologists
may or may not be immediately
comfortable using this technology so
thinking of
who you hire how to train staff is also
very important
but then the regulatory agencies the
decision makers both internally and
externally to companies
also need to be educated about what the
state of art is
and what it can and cannot do right now
and the work of our center and our
centers like ours is very important in
this regard
but finally what type of validation
really we need
to think about in terms of tissue chips
validation
is a very standard um and very well
defined process for in vitro methods
that replace animal tests
but fish achieve some far more
complicated and it's a technology that's
still being very actively developed
and the real validation the one that
exists in europe where there is a
network of
testing laboratories and whether it's a
ring trial
methodology this is really not that is
ready in my opinion right now for this
very
uh complicated technology and again
technology that is still in
early stages of development organic
validation you know this is kind of what
our center has been doing
you know sometimes felt like uh you know
very complicated
thing because these devices are um are
engineering devices and there are lots
of connections there are lots of
um tricks that you need to learn
and you really need to be ready for this
but finally
what i think really is going to take
hold and this is something where we're
working with next is the fit for purpose
validation
the industry that our users need to
define how the
you know what questions they think are
ready for tissue chips
and then that information has to be
embraced by developers
to be able to develop technology that
fits that particular question
rather than developing a technology that
replaces a particular animal or an organ
system
so i really appreciate your time
listening to this i'll be happy to
answer any questions
and with that i will conclude thank you